[Música]
ya son cinco días desde que inició la
invasión rusa ucrania dejando hasta el
momento un saldo que según el ministerio
defensa ucraniano es de trescientos
cincuenta y dos civiles muertos y al
menos mil 684 heridos además más de
medio millón de ucranianos han huido de
su país a naciones vecinas de acuerdo
con la agencia de naciones unidas para
los refugiados acnur ya de todo este
panorama hoy lunes 28 de febrero se
lleva a cabo en la frontera entre
belarús y ucrania unos diálogos entre
las dos delegaciones en conflicto para
así tratar de solucionar la situación y
poner en marcha un alto el fuego
inmediato
esta reunión se lleva a cabo luego de
que este fin de semana las tensiones
escalarán y después de que varias
sanciones económicas al contra rusia
fueron puestas en práctica por la unión
europea y sus aliados para analizar todo
lo que está pasando y todo lo que pasó
ya en los últimos días en las últimas
horas quiero saludar entonces a guido
larsson cientista político y máster en
relaciones internacionales gracias
querido por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 comenzamos
entonces por uno un análisis general de
lo que han sido estos cinco días de
invasión rusa en ucrania guido
mira diría que hay dos fases
características la primera fase las
primeras 48 horas caracterizada por un
uso del poder avasallador ruso por la
intención a mi juicio de generar
condiciones en terrenos que permitieran
una salida política bajo demandas
maximalistas de moscú esa primera fase
termina con una resistencia que
podríamos calificar incluso de heroica
por parte de los ucranianos liderada por
su presidente selenski dando pie
entonces a una nueva fase una fase
intermedia llamémosla así en donde se
intentan generar condiciones que creo yo
van a derivar en un alto al fuego
momentáneo que posiblemente contribuyan
a establecer un corredor humanitario
para la salida de civiles ucranianos de
su propio país pero me parece a mí que
en ningún caso implica un cese al fuego
definitivo porque ninguna de las
condiciones políticas que explicó el
inicio de la guerra en primer lugar van
a ser enfrentadas en esta reunión en
bielorrusia ahora también he ido hoy
como lo estábamos adelantando rusia y
ucrania se reúnen en su frontera común
para así buscar una solución a todo este
conflicto y un alto el fuego inmediato
esperanzas de que realmente se logre
esto hay esperanzas de que después de
estos diálogos o ya no veamos más
guerras y se logre finalmente el alto el
fuego
es un primer paso un primer paso
importante en generar el consenso en que
la idea de realizar acciones que
incrementen la confianza entre las
partes son un paso previo para una
salida definitiva sin embargo yo soy
pesimista respecto de que esta reunión
vaya a tener resultados a largo plazo y
que esta es una reunión que va abordar
temas inmediatos particularmente el tema
humanitario de los civiles ucranianos
pero no va a abordar el tema de fondo de
carácter político más aún es posible
aunque acá estamos especulando de que
esta semana la situación en terreno
después de la reunión incluso se empeore
porque hay señales de que rusia hasta el
momento ha ocupado apenas un tercio de
las fuerzas que tenía en la periferia de
ucrania y dado que esto se han alcanzado
los objetivos estratégicos que proponía
putin es posible que entonces la
violencia se incremente el paso es
relevante pero en ninguna medida me
parece a mí que es definitivo también
que yo entonces como separaría este
conflicto sino a lo mejor podemos
esperar mucho de estos diálogos que se
llevan a cabo
bueno sabemos cuál va a ser el mecanismo
de presión desde el lado occidental es
una presión económica es el intento de
asfixia económica hacia moscú es generar
condiciones que hagan que el conflicto
sea crecientemente costoso desde el
punto de vista político militar e
incluso diplomático pero una cosa que
cabe tener claro y es que más allá de
que hayan demandas que puedan ser
consideradas ilegítimas ninguna de las
causas políticas que explican la entrada
de rusia a la guerra se han abordado y
esas causas políticas son la ampliación
de la otan con dirección al este y la
sensación de inseguridad la federación
rusa respecto de este tipo de eventos
navi mover en la medida en que estos
eventos no se aborden va a ser muy
difícil salir del conflicto una
alternativa y solamente voy a terminar
con esto es potencialmente la finlandés
acción de ucrania vale decir de que
ucrania pasa a ser un país neutral que
mantenga relaciones cordiales con ambas
partes pero dada la circunstancia eso
realmente se ve muy difícil claro porque
además es precisamente hoy también el
presidente el presidente es el ente que
dijo a la unión europea que quería
formar parte inmediatamente del bloque
comunitario y parece pues que no serían
sus intenciones pero también hay otro
lado de la historia que me quería que
quisiera abordar con usted es la
atención también que hay por el anuncio
el presidente ruso vladimir putin de
poner en alerta a la disuasión nuclear
de su país qué tan preocupante está en
un si también o analistas comentan por
un lado que hay un signo de debilidad
por parte del líder ruso vladimir putin
y que sus tropas digamos no alcanzaron
sus objetivos en el tiempo que ellos o
que quisieron se encontraron mayor
resistencia de ucrania o rusia a lo
mejor también por otro lado está jugando
a una cierta debilidad para después
atacar con más fuerzas qué lectura le
podemos dar a todo esto bueno ya el solo
hecho que se esté mencionando el factor
nuclear debiera tomarse con enorme grado
de preocupación por muy improbable que
sea su uso a mi juicio es realmente
impensable imaginar una escala hacia ese
nivel sin embargo creo yo que la orden
que entrega a putin es una forma de
comunicar solapadamente de cuáles son
sus límites políticos y cuál es la
relevancia que el tema ucraniano tiene
para el todo esto además en un contexto
donde putin se ve obligado a responder a
las sanciones de occidente en tanto
desde el punto vista las sanciones
económicas como del envío de material
bélico hacia ucrania por ende tiene
estos dos vectores por un lado la idea
de que mediante el anuncio de esta
acción yo estoy comunicando
políticamente cuál es el escenario al
cual yo estoy dispuesto a llegar pero
por otro lado también incremento los
riesgos del conflicto porque lo que
usted está insinuando es muy importante
acá no se trata solamente de la
racionalidad del conflicto sino de cómo
en la medida en que estamos haciendo
acción tras acción salimos del ámbito de
lo puramente racional y controlado y
entramos en un escenario donde los
riesgos son más altos y donde se pueden
cometer errores no voluntarios que
deriven entonces en consecuencias mucho
más graves y yo me temo que ese riesgo
lo vamos a observar esta semana pues
vídeo todo está solera sobre la mesa un
escenario de todavía muy inestable
incluso con estos diálogos que se están
desarrollando la frontera entre belarús
y ucrania para tratar de terminar este
conflicto armado gracias por su tiempo
personales y por estar con nosotros en
el comerica de france 24